what does your experience in Counter
Narcotics investigating the Mexican drug
cartel teach you about human nature
wow I mean first off anybody can be God
anybody can be corrupted uh you know you
you work in that field then you you
realistically the training we got and
profiling and investigation and stuff
like stuff like that was basically you
learn from the older guys there and some
of those guys were already corrupted
from the from the start so
trust no one I remember seeing that
X-Files episode where that was stated
you quickly learn that even if you are
somebody that uh to your own mind
appears incorruptible
you know small changes happen around you
Wheels get greased the money gets put in
front of you and or things get
threatened like your life
and sometimes a payment for some of this
corruption is just to continue on living
you encounter people that seem
incorruptable that go through FBI
background checks that go through all of
the uh
the security measures that all of us
were put through through
um you know polygraph test and then
later on you know
it turns out they were on the take or
they became somebody that was corrupted
I think what I found out is that anybody
at any level they could be a very strong
hard to get person right now but uh
people get corrupted through their
families uh through need uh Mexico is a
place where a lot of uh instability
occurs
um so financial needs health so a crack
could form through the wall of integrity
and then over time it seeps in somehow
Mexico has a culture of corruption like
you know you have your kid that goes to
school at public school and you want him
to be in the morning not in the
afternoon School uh
time period so you go off and uh Grease
the wheels with the director of the
school people hearing this in Mexico
will nod their heads because this is
something that happens from early on so
there's a stomach there's a systemic and
cultural thing to it you know as far as
getting around rules and this happens
because you know the people are in
charge in Mexico the government is
you know there are their tandem amount
is trust between criminals and the
cartels down there for a lot of the
culture so people don't trust the
government and much less a criminality
so when you meet a person sticking on
human nature do you think it's possible
to figure out if they can be trusted so
you said um
anyone could be corrupted
you know how long would you need to talk
to a person
and you're even in your personal private
life just a friend
or is trust the thing that's never
really guaranteed I think God trust has
never really really guaranteed I know a
lot of people are going to say that's a
sad way and hard way of living your life
but you know life experience at my end
you know people change uh you know the
Dynamics of a relationship might change
I look at people's character
specifically their past and past
experiences if I can somebody that
presents himself in front of you as uh
somebody but you quickly learn that that
somebody is just a mask or a Persona
that they kind of uh created for
themselves and they might not even be
aware of the Persona like is there some
deep psychological stuff sometimes
I've experienced a lot of uh failure in
my life uh you can see it in my nose you
know you can see it in my lack of a
digit you know
um the amount of uh
you know the amount of failures you can
see in somebody and how they wear them
sometimes is a pretty telling thing as
far as them being able to be trusted or
that you can trust their story or their
experience
and when I say experience I mean I've
met some criminals like former criminals
or you know some some people of that
background that I trust with my life you
know because they're not not reformed uh
but they figured out that that's not not
a life they can live long enough to kind
of continue on and and I've also met
people that are in law enforcement that
I wouldn't trust with my car keys you
know
um because uh you know whatever Persona
they have adopted over the over the
years
is a pretty good one pretty good mask
sometimes such a good mask they don't
even know they're wearing it and on top
of that it's not just the psychology
there's also in your biology to it I've
I've been very fortunate and deliberate
to surround myself with good people
throughout my life
but I've recently gotten to sort of
observe not close to me but
nearby somebody that could be classified
as a sociopath yeah and and uh and a
narcissist like I I don't want to use
those psychological terms but just I
it's like oh people you know come with
different biology too so it's not just
like the the trauma you might experience
in your early life and all the Deep
complexity that leads uh all the Deep
complexity that leads to the the
psychology that you are to have as an
adult but it's also the biology come
with the the nature that you might not
just have the
the machine that can empathize deeply
with the experience of others or maybe a
machine that gets off gets a dopamine
Rush from the manipulation of other
humans yeah or the control of other
humans yeah I mean put an example of my
my own background uh my mom didn't have
a father you know she she uh he left
really early on in their in their
childhood you know my mom raised her two
sisters
and basically you kept a household uh
she was a great mom uh she was a badass
you know she was very independent she
showed me how to be independent she
showed me how to kind of watch out for
others and kind of build me up in that
way and uh I had a great childhood as
far as you know as far as her and kind
of like how she molded me later on I
figured out
that uh when I had my own kid
you know I I figured out that she was
basically trying to make me into what
she didn't have in a way
and if I can get to see somebody's
parents you know that's usually a that's
usually a sign of uh of something at
least for me as far as figuring out
where people are I think there's
something to be said about nature and
nurture and how some people come up some
people are just born with that uh
predatory Instinct you know uh and
you'll never know I mean they spend
their whole life practicing how to hide
it
uh but if you can figure out somebody's
you know background childhood where
they're from you can kind of tell
something about them you know I'm from
Tijuana you know I'm a Survivor that's
that's my background as far as where I'm
from
uh culturally genetically
psychologically
the full shebang yeah I guess some
people are born with a certain
predispositions and if they're in the
right environment some of the negative
aspects might flourish more than others
you know for me I mean I grew up
skateboarding in Tijuana
and I remember breaking into my first
backyard pool it was a house that a
cartel guy owned and we used to escape
the pool in the back in the back of it
uh so I learned how to pop open padlocks
uh with a uh with a small uh vehicle
hydraulic lift
and I remember doing that and uh later
on in life I got to train with people
from other parts of Mexico and
and work with them and I remember
pulling that trick off and they were
like looking at me like where'd you
learn that
it's like some burglars at Tijuana you
know and they're like wow that's
interesting like all all people from
Tijuana like that and I said no we're
not all like that but I guess in some
way we are because you know
Tijuana produces some produces kids like
that you know she produces like the
environment itself produces
uh produces a pretty specific person I
guess you know where our normal is our
normal or our Baseline normal is way
different than most the trajectories
that you can take in life are um are
defined in a way that aren't available
elsewhere in the world yeah and so you
develop I mean that's part of that
psychological part of that is cultural
and so on
um part of that is the cultural trauma
but then also the ethical lines based on
the corruption because I grew up in the
Soviet Union and this there's the same
kind of understanding that there's some
gray area of corruption yeah there's
always it's always there like in the on
the outskirts or even in the center how
you can grease things that make things
easier and how it's like a it's a
personal thing I'll just you know pay
off the in Tijuana we have a mortise
that's what we call it you know when you
when you pay a cop off means a bite
so and uh but what's uh what's the bite
aspect uh so you get stopped from for a
traffic violation of some sort and the
cop walks up to you obviously you don't
say the word bite but it's like a it's
like a slang term for it and uh he asked
uh for your paperwork and you know and
if you get fined or get a ticket you say
can I pay the ticket here is what they
say
and you know put their money inside the
paperwork in hand over to the cops you
think it's you know I'm just gonna do it
and nobody knows you know but it's a
systemic thing everybody but like a lot
of people do it and then they don't
trust the police because they are fed
with this
yeah I mean same thing was in the Soviet
Union it's funny but then there's
something inside you where that kind of
uh
those opportunities come like uh with a
police officer where you realize you
could just pay a little bit of money and
get out of a thing and then you realize
you can pay a little bit of money or do
a favor and get your kids in a better
school or something like that yeah but
there comes opportunities where you
where all right if if I do this little
thing I can make
I can get a huge promotion or I can get
a huge increase in my power or get a lot
of money and something inside you says
no yeah it's not right yeah and I wonder
what that is that because like uh
yeah because it feels different than the
legal systems when we operate there's
some kind of basic human Integrity human
decency I wonder if that's like
constructed or it's always there if it's
like again nature versus nurture yeah I
think uh you know for me it was looking
at seeing that in somebody else that I
kind of learned about it
uh there's a man that I consider a
mentor uh figure uh his name is
Lieutenant colonelizawla he was a
lieutenant colonel from the army that
basically came over and took over the
group that I used to work with uh
he was you know Incorruptible you know
he was uh that that was the the essence
or the the aura that he projected
um the first time he the first time he
went off on patrol when he was placed in
charge of us I actually you know drove
him around Tijuana
uh he was one of those lead from the
front type of people uh
the amount of assassination attempts he
got was basically a proof of how
uncorruptable he was because he kept
trying to pay him off and when that
didn't work they tried to kill him
several times I think the last
assassination attempt took the use of
his legs
and that man is still a dangerous person
in my mind but for me and you know
people can gather a little bit about my
background and where I'm from and some
of the access I currently have to train
the federal institutions here in the US
as far as my background and if I was
corrupted or not because there's a lot
of that out there
um the
the Catholic guilt that's kind of built
into some of us is always kind of there
you know
the devil was under the bed you know
uh so I I don't consider myself Catholic
consider myself culturally Catholic I
think is what what I kind of kind of say
with that I had a pretty good structure
with my dad and my mom at the house and
you know they never let me get away with
uh things
and uh I think my mom was pretty a
pretty big moral compass for me but uh
that Lieutenant Colonel uh kind of
leading from example and seeing his work
and how
how much profound change it caused in
the people that work with him as far as
you know we felt supported and we felt
like we had a guiding figure uh during
this
Tijuana was the most dangerous city on
the planet when I was working there and
he took charge what does it take to be a
man the lieutenant colonel
who maintains Integrity after
assassination attempts is it possible
for a normal human to do that or again
as a genetics that's an interesting
question I'll say this uh seeing him I
mean the last assassination attempt he
had that took a use of his legs he was
with his kid
uh there was a recklessness to it you
know I I can see that now like now that
I have enough distance from it I could
see that there's a recklessness to being
that way uh and also you putting
Jeopardy people around you if you take
that route
so I think there's a sacrifice to it a
very powerful and hard one to make for a
lot of people uh
for me it was I wouldn't get picked to
get on on board with some of the
operations groups that I wanted to work
with because I was known for not you
know taking money for
not being trusted by certain older
segments of the of the organization that
I was with with stuff because they knew
that I wouldn't you know I wasn't on the
you know they I wouldn't get money
um so there's that there's there's
always a weird sacrifice to it and
you're almost kind of like masochistic
in that way when you
when you when you when you get
approached with it they're like why are
you being an idiot you know why are you
why are you driving around that beat up
car look at the Hummer H2 that just
drove in with the other guy that is
doing exactly your same job
um
Society Society there's a hole down
there
doesn't reward it or at least doesn't
see it in the people that don't take
that route in Mexico you know for them
it's all cops are corrupt you know all
of them uh and
you know seeing it you know again from
the outside I'm not there anymore
uh there is you know there's almost like
a why didn't you Ed you know
um that could have been easier maybe or
you could have you could have been dead
long ago you know because people that
are on the take down there are usually
owned by one side or the other and when
that gets found out you know if you have
somebody that you're paying off that uh
hints you off of drug operations of the
area
your Rivals are pretty keen on killing
you